[Music]
thank you very very much for coming and
braving the heat um uh in this tent um
i'm just a times columnist doesn't
matter who i am but the chap on my right
who i've known for a ridiculously long
time and this really is
a kind of crumbly convention up here on
the on the stage but full of
intellectual vigor
um uh is peter manelson who how many
jobs did you do in government in the end
and how many cabinets almost the same
number as i
lost
well it must be that's by definition
yeah
you know i
you know navigated my way through
appointments and defenestrations over a
period of 13 years your business
secretary
no first of all i was the prime
minister's minister in the minister
without portfolio in the cabinet office
oh yeah which i absolutely hated because
it didn't have a portfolio well because
i didn't have a portfolio because i had
to sort of stuck like a sort of glue to
t blair and i wanted to go off and do my
own thing then i became secretary of
state for trade and industry
left
then i came back as secretary of state
for northern ireland
left
then i went to europe as trade
commissioner
and then was summoned back literally at
a day's notice by gordon brown when the
global financial crisis truck
so you did a lot of jobs in government
and you've been in politics for a long
time before that you had been a lambeth
councillor back in the days of and now
unless you are over 50 you will not know
this
red ted knight yes red ted knight was
the leader of lambeth council
when i was elected and when i was
elected to it he said well at least
we've got some of my own people elected
at the same time pity about you
we were both members of the labour party
but you wouldn't have thought so yeah
red ted was called red ted by his
friends as well as by his enemies so
he was actually a trotskyist wasn't he
he was a trotskyist
paid for by
gaddafi if i remember who was backing
some trotskyite faction at the time and
they had a newspaper that was called
labor uh herald and they were sort of
pretty close knit into the whole
ken livingstone sort of trotskyist
brigade during the
1970s 80s now the reason for talking
about red ted a little bit uh and
lambeth a little bit is because the new
labour project which you were
associated with
no which you it helped initiate if
indeed you did not initiate back in the
mid 80s
partially came out of a need to deal
with the damage that been done to labor
by
in your perception by these people like
red ted knights yeah that was the
previous near-death experience before
the one we've just experienced
yes the jeremy corbyn the death
experience so
um
the only reason for i wanted to kind of
introduce the new labour experience was
that labour has been here before
we have been here before
we
did fight back but it took us 18 long
years to get back into government in
1997
and that was essentially what the
first period of government that we
were
elected to in the last 50 years just by
way of illustration i was 24
when margaret thatcher was elected i was
42 by the next time a labour government
came into power and it's important for
people to understand what that means i
think
yes particularly given our present
yeah
because now the conservatives have been
in power for in one way or another for
11 years yep
and so on and people think they're going
to be re-elected at the next election
so
first and we have to disabuse them of
that idea
yeah
let's well let's disabuse them at the
end what i'm interested in really is
that's a kind of long view of politics
you took
labour party helped take the labour
party to a position of electability it
was elected three times so on you were
in government so you weren't just having
ideas about stuff you then had to do
things
in 2001 began a series of what you might
call cataclysms which have continued to
these days maybe say we could say four
of them so let's go to the first one
first
there's new labour doing new laboury
kind of things and then 9 11 happens
almost exactly 20 years ago
can you tell me what effect that had on
what you thought you were doing i think
it
had two effects one it
wrenched the prime minister tony blair
away from his domestic agenda which was
focused on the reform and overhaul and
new delivery of public services
wholesale reform of education of schools
the opening up of the university
sector
the reform and overhaul of healthcare
delivery all he was doing on
with the
neighborhood crime and the respect
agenda it wrenched him away from a
domestic agenda and put him very firmly
front of
stage
in what subsequently
became known as the war on terrorism
and the second effect it had was that it
brought home to you the extent to which
your
welfare
your safety your security
and an awful lot of the things that you
take for granted in your life is
dependent on effective state
action
i would say 9 11
in the whole
security and policing an intelligent
sphere
was the first of a succession of events
that reminded us that
we need the state we need an effective
and smart state not just a big state and
that it had to be managed and reformed
well in order to serve the needs of uh
the
the the people who put us there because
the global financial crisis did the same
well and the pandemics just done the
same well we'll come on to those in a
moment and now climate change is going
to do the same for us as well to go onto
it now if you like no no no no no no no
no
you're in the driving seat here not me
yes yeah so i'm just making a point that
i mean for the first 75
years of the last century we saw it's a
relentless growth of the state
and then with mrs thatcher's arrival
because a lot of people in the country
started questioning whether we needed
such a big state whether we were getting
value for money from that state whether
it's the services for which it was
responsible uh we're really
delivering and meeting
our needs and people also got slightly
fed up with the cost
of an ever-growing state
and i think that what's happened in
politics fundamentally
is that we are seeing a return
of the state
but in my view and i feel this very
passionately
the labour party hasn't simply got to be
a cheerleader for a bigger state that is
not the way to electoral success in my
view
we have got to produce ideas
for a different better smarter
delivery of services and the meeting of
needs by the state otherwise you know
people and also to
maintain a grip and a disciplined status
hold over the public finances that fund
that state
or we are going to face the same
near-death experience
now that we experienced
after the 1970s okay and i want to take
you right back to where we were
before that interesting period
because the thing because you've stated
in a sense what we need to do
but what 2001 shows and this is why
we've kind of pushed it in there is
circumstances i mean what's the famous
phrase events yeah if you want to make
god laugh tell him your plans
uh and so on is the old uh is the old
expression events huge events
completely act to disrupt your capacity
to do things and that's as if
and that's without the fact that
actually doing them was difficult enough
in the first place saying stuff easy
doing stuff very difficult you were in
government and you were doing that so
2001 wrenches your prime minister away
it gives you iraq
unfortunately yes yeah which makes which
makes them very unpop uh very unpopular
um but not popular enough to put the
tories then and then as if that's not
enough towards the end of
of labor's uh period in power you again
get the crash now how does that impact
upon labour well it impacts us
in two ways it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas